Esto le impediría al señor eh Puigdemont
presentarse a las elecciones catarnas,
no presentarse.
Podría presentar eh porque ya lo hizo
si recordamos en las elecciones del año 2 020,
si no recuerdo mal em
el tema aquí es
qué VA a hacer la junta electoral central también
si vuelve, porque si vuelve
la junta electoral central,
lo que tiene que emitir es si su candidatura es legal.
Tenemos que ver,
por ejemplo desde su le
la legalidad o vigencia a su DNI.
Nosotros ya sabe que hemos eh anunciado que
eh desde la delegación de océanos europeos
eh llevaremos a la junta electoral central
la candidatura del señor pues de Mon,
y luego que hasta donde yo sé,
el estatuto de autonomía de Cataluña
exige a cualquier candidato
que esté censado en Cataluña,
y yo no sé dónde está censado el señor pues de Mon,
por ponerle 2 ejemplos,
y luego la tercera,
que lo que le acabo de decir de la perjudicial
implica que el procedimiento se suspende,
es decir, que si el señor pulsemón pone 1 pie
en Cataluña o en España,
pasa a disposición judicial de manera inmediata,
y ya sabemos que si pasa a disposición judicial
1 acautelar puede perfectamente
decir que está inhabilitado para cargo público.
Es que todo lo que están haciendo es simplemente
continuar con esta bola de nieve
que no les VA a llevar a ningún a ningún sitio.
Y pues es muy interesante lo que me cuenta